hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 5
recap and review dedicado imax marks the
midway point of the season and brings
some heavy duty scheming with Kym and
Jimmy this is your spoiler warning if
you haven't watched episode 5 yet this
video will spoil everything that's
happened and better call Saul and
Breaking Bad up until this point so go
watch the episode first and come back
and watch this review after just hit the
subscribe button and turn on
notifications before you leave because I
will be making videos on better call
Saul until the end of the series since
season 5 has been filled with strong
episodes this one probably won't rank in
the top of the list when things are said
and done but I do love the character
work in dedicado MX Kim's journey is
fascinating as we see her not being able
to stop even when Jimmy advises her -
their chemistry always heats up when
they're scheming together and it's
always fun to watch Saul in action the
mic side of things is a little less
engaging but it also delivered some gems
so let's start there Mike did turn out
to be in Mexico we didn't get the
details on how Gus got him there but
that is in fact what happened
he's on a ranch or a compound that Gus
funds there's a memorial there to his
partner max we see the episode titles
name comes from a plaque that is
revealed on the back of the fountain
Mike's here because he's been on a
bender that's led him to be out in the
street fighting Street hoods as Gus
pointed out deep down he knows that this
is not a path that he can continue on
but he's on that because his interaction
with Gus led to healing Werner who was a
good person so we see Mike's actions
lead him to a place where he has to make
a decision that he doesn't want to make
there's some good comedy and Mike's time
in this compound Jimmy calls him and he
asked him if he's in a tunnel because
there's some reverb and Mike just says
yes I'm in a tunnel
also he decides that he needs to charge
his phone so he goes in and he's
starting to try to build a charger
himself MacGyver style I guess and the
woman who's taking care of him just
walks into the room with the right
charger that he needs I liked in the
opening how whenever he came
we saw the chickens walking by and that
was a callback to when we see him
feeding the chickens and breaking bad
when he's in the care of the same doctor
dr. Goodman and all of it is solid
enough as far as we see that Mike is in
this situation health-wise this is
probably good for him he doesn't seem to
be drinking while he's there I think
where it's a little bit weak is that
none of this really convinces him that
Gus is a better person and Gus doesn't
even try to use that as his way in he
essentially says it doesn't make up for
anything he is what he is and this is
where they go with it rather than having
him trying to win Mike over to his side
because he actually is different for
good reasons it comes down to the fact
that he thinks that Mike can understand
doing these sorts of things for revenge
he doesn't come out and explain what we
know about what happened between the
Salamanca's and Max but knowing what we
know about Mike we know that he did go
out and kill the people the other police
officers who were responsible for Maddy
so there is something there they have in
common so where I don't think that it
really did a great job of making it like
oh yeah now I get it that's why Mike is
on Gus's side and Breaking Bad it all
makes perfect sense now maybe there'll
be some more that'll happen it doesn't
look like that it's completely resolved
at this point but we see how Gus is
trying to get to Mike and it's hard
because we would rather Mike go home be
grandpa to Caylee take care of his
family and just sit back on the
sidelines at the same time we know
that's not gonna happen because we've
already seen where he ends up and
Breaking Bad Kim on the other hand we
don't know where she ends up we don't
know how she gets out of Jimmy's life by
the time that we meet him as Saul and
Breaking Bad and we get a pretty good
idea of how things might go wrong for
her character if you've been watching my
videos you know that I've been thinking
about this a lot and sure enough Kim and
Jimmy are planning things out there one
step ahead we see that play out
throughout this episode up until the
point that Kevin won't
they set up mr. Acker to be the problem
and Kevin just can't let it go he can't
let Acker get away with it even when
presented with an out that will solve
the problem he just won't let go and
it's great that we see this mirrored and
Kim who up until this point has mostly
done these scams and done this stuff
with Jimmy in situations where nobody
gets hurt in this episode we see her
lying we see her putting her job in
jeopardy this plays out pretty
fantastically whenever Schweiker comes
in and says look they might not see what
you're doing but I see that this has to
be something that you're involved with
and rather than take the out there she
does the same thing she doubles down and
it's crazy to see her not be able to let
go of this I'm guessing this will lead
to some kind of reveals about her past
there's something more that we don't
know yet about this character that is
driving this decision-making
it's wild in the midst of this that we
see a lot more Jimmy coming through
rather than Saul it's fun to see him
acting ass all in full scheming mode
he's certainly in his element there but
he's the one who shifts to be the voice
of reason when it's time to give up the
game before we get into one of my
favorite scenes of this season it is
worth mentioning that we had a Howard
sighting in episode 5 he's at home
looking very well with the Tibetan
singing bowl on his table he's just
checking in with Jimmy Jimmy assures him
that he's taking great time to consider
this offer but we know he's not gonna go
with it and I'm interested to see how
the Howard side of things play out but
there's really nothing else to discuss
there after the call Kim comes home and
he wants to hear everything about what
happened with Kevin we see his attention
to detail here in grifting the side
sitter
comment was hilarious and it all plays
out like a mentor and a student kind of
situation where he's pointing out these
details
Jimmy has her do an impression of Kevin
he does an impression of her it's
interesting to see how he knows her so
much better hers is more of a Karen
secure of him whereas Jimmy really kind
of nails Kim in his depiction it's funny
because you actually see her do the same
things with her
hands later that he does right here
whenever he's playing her all of this
turns Jimmy on and I really enjoyed how
this escalates how they stay in
character just a great scene all the way
around but as much as he enjoys this he
does try to put on the brakes later it's
not until she absolutely insists on
moving forward that Jimmy says that they
can go after Kevin personally he says
it's going to be personal it's going to
get dangerous after trying to get Mike
on the job as their private investigator
Jimmy's forced to go through the
veterinarian again that brings us to mr.
X he's played by Stephen hog we saw him
when Mike was doing security the problem
here is this that Kevin isn't dirty
there's nothing that they can find Jimmy
calls out mr. X implying that he didn't
do a very thorough job it turns out that
that is not the case we see that he did
and Kevin just doesn't have anything
going on things escalate to mr. X saying
he'd take him out into the desert and
get some answers out of him they shut it
down but the big thing here is that
they've crossed the line kim has crossed
the line and they're pursuing things
that could lead in dangerous directions
in the end it seems like she may have
come up with something that is related
to their logo perhaps maybe there's a
copyright infringement or something
along those lines I didn't exactly
understand what she saw in those photos
but it has something to do with the Mesa
Verde logo and she thinks she found a
way to get something on Kevin as
mentioned though rich comes in he knows
that there's something going on he tries
to give Kim an out she doesn't take it
she makes a scene in the office when she
demands to know if he's suggesting
there's some malfeasance or something
else going on and the thing about it is
he is right she is doing something wrong
and she can't let it go
so there's something going on with Kim
something about this situation it's not
about mr. Acker it's not really about
what mr. Acker said it seems to me that
Kevin
Mesa Verde perhaps rich and Stewart and
Cokely as well they all have something
to do with the way she's reacting to
this situation like I said I think it
probably has something to do with her
past and I'm excited to see where
everything goes of course it's the same
thing as with Mike he'd love to see her
pull it back you'd love to see her come
to her senses because we care about
these characters because this show has
written them in a way that we do it's an
exciting time to be a fan so yeah this
was a good episode even if it probably
isn't the best episode of this season it
has a lot of competition there I enjoyed
all the scheming but in reality how
necessary was it I liked watching Mike
work through his solitude in Mexico but
again like how important is that stuff
really I know a lot of people were
hoping we'd get more about Gus's
backstory so there's a little bit of
disappointment there it does add some
depth to his character at least as far
as Mike's concerned but we already knew
he was motivated by revenge
the Salamanca's are obviously bad people
but Gus is as well if anything I think
that it's kind of interesting because of
the fact that you know that idea
everybody's the hero and their own story
and I do like how they have Gus saying
like hey you know what I am a bad person
I own that and I'm doing it for revenge
I'd like to see them pull more out of
Mike's story as far as why he ended up
being the person that we saw we'll see
how it goes I'm gonna let it go there
let me know in the comments what you
think what you're excited about what you
want to see happen in the rest of the
season please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching I will talk to you soon
you